Bernie Sanders who is a Senator running for
the 2020 democratic party press
essential nomination has published his immigration
plan and it's a good one.
It's comprehensive and it deals with the major
issues that are surrounding immigration.
And one of the most important things about
this plan, which we're going to look at today
in some detail, is that there's the policy
stuff that is immediately related to immigration,
DACA, a child separations, but it's a plan
that is comprehensive in that it deals with
the issue as it exists in the real world,
which is connected to so many other issues.
And this is one of the things that there's
like a myopia that often takes place in politics
around controversial issues where each side,
and I'm not playing a both sides game, but
both sides do this to some degree.
Each side sort of buckles down in arguing
in a narrow way about particular elements
of a policy issue without considering in a
serious way the circumstances and the context
in which it exists.
And when you look at something like immigration,
immigration relates to education, law enforcement,
healthcare, trade economics, all of these
other things that if you really want to deal
with it in a serious adult way, you have to
consider, and Bernie Sanders plan does that.
So this'll be good.
It's good to sometimes step back from the
polls and the tweets.
This is Bernie's immigration plan and some
of the components that are included.
The right likes to talk about deportations
and the wall crossing the border is criminal
detain people, charge them, get them out,
doesn't deal with the circumstances and the
conditions that got us to where we are today.
And that's one of the best things about this
plan.
So, uh, Bernie Sanders would end child separations
at the border.
Okay.
That's a specific action that can be taken
of via a directive.
Uh, that's a good start.
Bernie would reunite, separated children with
families.
Make sense to do.
Doesn't mean people are not going to be held
accountable if they've committed crimes.
It's not a opening the door to lawlessness
like the right likes to suggest.
It just makes sense to do it.
Auditing and closing detention centers.
You don't necessarily need to close all of
them.
And Bernie Sanders is not claiming that he
would, he would audit the entire system.
He would look at the conditions that are taking
place within individual detention centers
and he would figure out which ones need to
be reformed and which ones need to be closed.
Very, Bernie would put a moratorium on all
deportations.
Now this is a controversial element here because
even among many on the left in the democratic
party, uh, within the house and Senate, there
are not that many people who say, stop all
deportations.
But what Bernie Sanders is saying here is
at least as we sort out some of these other
elements, let's put a moratorium on deportations
because they're, uh, th th once you've rung
that bell, once the genie is out of the bottle,
once we've deported someone, um, the ability
to undo that if we decide that the policy
is changing is extremely limited, stopping
all construction of the border wall.
Obvious.
Now you might say, I didn't think that the
border wall was even under construction.
Um, so we've got elements of the wall that
are being replaced with Donald Trump's version
of the wall that were scheduled for replacement.
As we know, you can either climb over them
as some have done, you can get $100 saw at
any hardware store and saw through it.
So it's not a, a virtually impenetrable fence
has Donald Trump has claimed it to be.
But Bernie is saying here, just cut and dry,
whatever it is that's going on.
If and when he becomes president in terms
of construction of a border wall, we're going
to stop that.
And overturning the Muslim ban as well.
Of course, Trump is say it's not really a
Muslim ban.
Uh, we've had that debate.
That is a policy that doesn't make any sense.
It's a policy that doesn't make sense on the
merits because it's targeting countries that
have not actually been the sources of people,
uh, who come to the United States and do things,
do violent things, commit terrorist acts.
So on the merits, it doesn't make sense.
And also in terms of what it signals in terms
of the, the sort of ambience or atmosphere
that's such a policy creates.
It's not doing anything for us and it's actually
doing a lot against us.
So Bernie would stop that.
Then we get into some of the key elements
of the immigration debate, one of which is
DACA deferred action for childhood arrivals,
child arrivals, meaning individuals who even
if they are older than 18 today, 18 or older
today, they came to the United States as miners
brought by their parents.
And it doesn't make sense to punish people
for circumstances that are not of their doing.
Bernie would extend DACA to the 1.8 million
who are currently eligible for it and also
allow those who have been in the United States
undocumented for more than five years to remain
without threat of deportation.
And as we know, if you are here, even if you're
not a committing criminal acts as almost all
undocumented immigrants are not doing, and
all of those, uh, circumstances are true.
If you know you face deportation, you are
not going to be contributing to society.
And the way that you otherwise would be able
to and would choose to because that fear of
deportation would keep you hidden.
It would keep you in circumstances where you're
not a productive member of society.
That's a good thing.
But then what's the bigger picture of that?
The path to citizenship?
Bernie would, and I liked that he's being
upfront about this piece.
Bernie would push Congress for a path to citizenship
for the 11 million who are already here in
the United States, undocumented living and
working today.
And Bernie's being upfront, he's not saying
I will do this because he can't do this.
It is something he needs to push Congress
to do and he's being clear about that in the
plan.
A importantly, things like marijuana possession
and other, uh, um, uh, you know, nonviolent
of violations of the law will not block the
path to citizenship.
That makes absolute and total sense.
And I like that that is included here.
A Bernie would also repeal, uh, the eight
us code section 13, 25, which puts border
crossings on par with other types of immigration
violations, like overstaying a visa.
It would not, it would change the circumstances
where a border crossing has some higher criminal
consideration that simply overstaying a visa
does not.
It would put it all on par.
Now as far as immigration agencies, Bernie
wants to break up ice and customs and border
patrol, but not eliminate the function.
Simply redistribute them.
And this is an important thing because on
the one hand you have ice and CBP which are,
uh, extraordinarily mismanaged, inefficient
and involved in a lot of things that we want
to curtail.
But at the same time, if you simply say abolish
ice and CBP and eliminate their functions
altogether, you will get of large contingent
of the American public saying that is a responsible.
So what Bernie would do is he would bring
back the enforcement of deportations and of
a border investigative authority to the department
of justice.
Doesn't mean we eliminated, we simply move
it from ice and CBP back to DOJ.
Customs authority would go from CBP back to
the treasury department the way it used to
be and the naturalization and citizenship
authority would be given back to the state
department.
Makes absolute and total sense now is when
we start getting into the really interesting
stuff.
You know, that this is a thoughtful and well-crafted
plan because Bernie is including elements
like strengthening immigrant labor rights
in immigration reform, which have a place
there that's exactly what we should be doing.
So for example, there will be a whistle blower
visa established to protect immigrant workers
who are reporting exploited of actions by
employers.
One of the ways in which big corporations
remain the major beneficiaries of undocumented
immigration is that they have, um, of of all,
almost carte blanche to have horrible working
conditions, uh, because they know that they're
undocumented workers that they are employing,
which by the way is against the law.
But good luck holding them accountable.
We're not doing it.
Um, they know that they are not in a position
to go and report those conditions for fear
of deportation.
A whistleblower visa would protect them, restructuring
work visas to make them portable.
Because when you have a work visa that is
tied to one employer, only that employee is
trapped at that employer.
And again, it diminishes, diminishes their
labor rights and labor power.
Very great.
Absolutely fantastic thing to do.
Ending workplace raids and shifting the focus
of the employment of the enforcement from
the workers to the employers.
I've been talking about this for years.
You've got to deal with the employers here.
Bernie would do that.
Protecting farm workers.
There's lots of ways that Bernie does.
This.
One is requiring at least a $15 minimum wage
and overtime pay for agricultural workers.
They, uh, there are all these exemptions for
agricultural workers from a lot of the labor
laws that protect other workers.
You've got to get rid of those loopholes.
Medicare for all.
Now you might say, wait a second.
What does Medicare for all have to do with
immigration?
Everything.
When you look at the disparities in health
care, along racial lines and among immigrant
versus domestically born, uh, if you are going
to comprehensively do immigration reform,
you need to deal with, uh, the system that
we have, which doesn't work and Medicare for
all is Bernie's way of dealing with it.
Bernie also says that he will use executive
orders whenever possible.
Now, I think that this is both smart and honest.
Bernie is saying, uh, I can't use executive
orders for all of these things.
Bernie is not pretending that he can just
snap his finger and create a path to citizenship
for undocumented immigrants.
Even if that's what he would like to do on
that issue, he will push Congress to do it
where he can use executive orders, he will
use them and he will also work to undo the
work.
Uh, the disastrous work that Donald Trump
has done on this issue via executive orders.
There's a lot more and sub points to many
of these, but these are the primary things.
So question one, now Ken, Bernie just do this
stuff.
If he becomes president, the answer is no,
of course not.
And he's being upfront about the elements
that he can't do by himself.
But that's okay.
A campaign policy platform is merely the starting
point.
It is what the candidate would like, but let's
at least start from the right place, right?
We don't start healthcare negate what we did,
uh, under a former president.
But we shouldn't start healthcare negotiations
under we, we would, we would like a public
option if, if it's okay, but if not, we'll
just do Obamacare.
No, we start the negotiations from the morally
and ethically correct place that is in line
with our values and what we would like to
see.
And you negotiate from there.
So here's how I would sum up what our immigration
policy should be as a principal or as a value
for starting the negotiation and the right
claims to love this stuff.
The right doesn't really want to do the work
of the nitty gritty.
The right loves to say, here are our values,
here are our principles.
These will guide us and give us all of the
answers.
They don't, by the way, but let's do it.
Here's the principle from which our policies
on immigration should follow.
Let's treat people like human beings.
Let's treat human beings like people.
Let's not punish people for circumstances
beyond their control.
And let's live up to the standards that make
the United States what it is or at least what
it is supposed to be, period.
Okay.
All of the correct policies follow from that
if you apply it responsibly and if you apply
it in a thoughtful way to all elements of
the immigration situation and as Bernie Sanders
plan points out, that includes healthcare,
that includes labor rights, that includes
actually buckling down on employers who are
breaking the law yet go virtually unpunished.
So a really good plan from Bernie Sanders
on this issue.
If there are things missing from it that you
would like to see, let me know.
I'll give you one example of something I would've
liked to see more of.
One of the most important factors in influencing
a, the number of people that want to come
to the United States legally or illegally
are the circumstances in their home country
that they are coming from.
And so one of the additional things that I
would love to see more of in a serious and
comprehensive immigration plan is ideas or
policies for how we can modify our relationship
or improved circumstances.
In some of the source countries such that
our relationships with those countries will
imp improve economically.
We'll be, we will be better off by virtue
of helping their economies and we will just
reduce the demand for the number of people
that are trying to come over to the United
States who are willing to do so illegally.
That is what I would like to see more of in
the plan, but I want to hear from you as well.
I'm on Twitter at D Pacman.
The show is on Twitter at David Pakman show
and we have a [inaudible]
packed program for you today